[Applaus]
[Musik]
liebe visualpolitik Community zwischen
September 2021 und im Mai dieses Jahres
hat er japanische Yen eine der
wichtigsten Währungen der Welt rund ein
Fünftel seines Wertes gegenüber dem
Dollar verloren zum ersten Mal seit zwei
Jahrzehnten lag der Wert des Dollar über
130 Yen ein Tiefpunkt die er seit über
20 Jahren nicht mehr gesehen wurde
[Musik]
und das ist noch nicht alles denn seit
der Yen Mitte 2012 eine Rekordhoch
gegenüber dem US-Dollar erreichte hat
die japanische Währung in den letzten
Jahren rund 40% ihres Wertes verloren
die Fragen mit denen wir uns heute in
diesem Video beschäftigen wollen lauten
daher warum fällt der Jen immer weiter
warum schaltet so viel an lusten und
sogar die japanische Regierung selbst zu
beunruhigen was gedenkt die japanische
Regierung zu tun und welche Folgen
könnte die epochale jensschwäche für die
gesamte Weltwirtschaft haben seid ihr
bereit na dann lasst uns sofort loslegen
ein Schlag mit Ankündigung
das Jahr 2022 brach der weltweit eine
große wirtschaftliche wendem mit sich
nach vielen Zweifeln zahlreichen zögern
und einem sehr langsamen Start scheint
der Markt nun völlig überzeugt zu sein
die Federal Reserve wird die
aggressivste Straffung ihrer Geldpolitik
die wir in den letzten Jahrzehnten
gesehen haben durchführen da die
Inflation alle Prognosen übersteigt
werden die Zinsen wohl drastisch steigen
nun auf jeden Fall in den USA in Japan
hingegen sehen die Dinge völlig anders
aus während die Fett die Absicht
verkündete die Inflation durch
Leistungserhöhungen zu bekämpfen machte
die japanische Zentralbank die Bank of
Japan hingegen ihre Entscheidung
deutlich dass sie alle ihre zur
Verfügung stehenden Mittel nutzen wird
um die Rendite 10-jähriger japanischer
Staatsanleihen auf unbestimmte Zeit bei
0,25% zu deckeln um euch mal eine
Relation zu geben die Rendite der
zehnjährigen US-Staatsanleihe hatte
Anfang Mai 2022 die 3% Marke
überschritten
aber wie kann eine Zentralbank überhaupt
die Renditen von Staatsanleihen
begrenzen ich meine habt ihr eine Idee
ganz genau indem sie massive Mengen an
Staatsschulden mit neuem Geld aufkauft
das wird im volksmond auch als
Gelddrucken bezeichnet und allein die
Ankündigung dessen war wohl schon zu
viel des Guten große Teil der Anleger
und Sparer begann nämlich danach ihre
jensuliquidieren und in US-Dollar
umzutauschen das Ziel nun ihre
Ersparnisse zu schützen und zu versuchen
eine höhere Rendite erzielen zu können
denn es ist klar dass die 0,25%
japanischen Regierung es kaum wert sind
vor allem wenn man dabei die aktuellen
Inflationsraten im Hinterkopf hat
tatsache ist jedoch dass diese Reaktion
laut oecd-daten dazu geführt hat dass
nun der Yen gegenüber dem Dollar so
stark unterbewertet ist wie gesagt mehr
als 30 Jahren nicht mehr dies bedeutet
jedoch noch lange nicht dass er seinen
Tiefpunkt schon erreicht hätte der große
Unterschied zwischen der Geldpolitik der
USA und Japans könnte die japanische
Währung noch weiter unter Druck setzen
noch weiter nach unten ziehen
aber warum sind die Japaner eigentlich
so versessen darauf die Renditen von
Staatsanleihen zu begrenzen warum
behärtet Bank of Japan darauf ihre ultra
expansive Geldpolitik weiter anzuheizen
was will sie damit bezwecken nun ja
zunächst einmal können wir annehmen dass
es einerseits darum geht die japanische
Regierung zu retten oder es ist
zumindest kurzfristig leichter zu machen
immer mehr auszugeben ohne dies
beispielsweise durch Steuererhöhungen
Decken zu müssen vergesst bitte nicht
das wir über ein Land sprechen indem die
nominale Staatsverschuldung 240% des BIP
beträgt so dass ein Anstieg der Rendite
auf die Staatsverschuldung auf ein oder
1,5 % die japanische Regierung allein
ein Zinsen mehr als 120 Milliarden
Dollar pro Jahr kosten könnte aber nein
das ist nicht der einzige Beweggrund die
Wahrheit ist dass die hierarischen in
Tokio schon seit einigen Jahren zu einem
ganz bestimmten Schluss gekommen sind
nämlich dass die japanische Wirtschaft
nur durch eine Ausweitung der Exporte
wieder in Schwung gebracht werden kann
und in Zusammenhang damit glauben Sie
auch dass sie zur Aufrechterhaltung
ihrer steigenden Wettbewerbsfähigkeit
vor allem einen schwachen brauchen damit
japanische Produkte auf dem
internationalen Markt billiger angeboten
und somit stärker nachgefragt werden
[Musik]
andererseits dürfen wir doch auch nicht
vergessen dass eines der Hauptziel der
japanischen Zentralbanken grundsätzlich
darin besteht die Inflation anzuheizen
bzw die Deflation zu bekämpfen dass ich
Japan seit dem Krisen in 1990er Jahre
immer noch langfristig in einer
deflationären Spirale befindet
zusätzlich leidet das Land aufgrund der
demografischen Entwicklungen und einem
erheblichen Rückgang der
Erwerbsbevölkerung was die Preise weiter
deflationär unter Druck setzt deshalb
will die japanische Zentralbank den
Export ankurbeln und sowohl
Investitionen als auch den Konsum durch
Kredite sowie zusätzliche Geldspritzen
weiter fördern aber Moment Ziele sind
zwar schön und gut aber sie sind nur die
eine Seite der Medaille Ergebnisse
hingegen sind eine ganz andere denn
aufgepasst viele westlicher Lüsten
meinen dass diese Politik sich als ein
großer Fehler erweisen könnte und ihr
fragt euch sicherlich schon was denn da
so alles schief gehen kann nun
aufgepasst
[Musik]
das Verborgene Gesicht der Abwertung
im Jahr 2021 was zeichnete Japan ein
durchschnittliches monatliches
handelssliches 2 Milliarden US-Dollar
wenn wir uns die Daten für die letzten
Jahre ansehen können wir leicht
feststellen dass die Außenhandelsbilanz
seit 2012 in negativ ist und das obwohl
der Jens seitdem schon 40% seines Wertes
verloren hat
[Musik]
außerdem machen Japans Exporte schon
etwa 17,5% seines BIP aus ein höherer
Prozentsatz als jeder der USA aber in
vielen niedrigerer als der von Ländern
wie Kanada oder Großbritannien die rund
ein Viertel ihres DEP durch Exporte
generieren und ganz zu schweigen von
Deutschland wo die Exporte bisher sogar
47% des BIP ausgemacht haben fast
dreimal so viel als im Lande aufgehenden
Sonne das heißt obwohl wir alle japans
Wirtschaft weltweit mit seinen
hochwertigen Exportprodukten in
Verbindung bringen schalte japanische
Wirtschaft anhand der vorliegenden Daten
noch keine wirkliche Exportnation zu
sein im Gegenteil die japanische
Wirtschaft ist er in einem hohen Maße
von der Einfuhr aller Arten von Gütern
und vor allem Rohstoffen abhängig wenn
wir dann dazu noch den Anstieg der
Energie Lebensmittel und Rohstoffpreise
und dann sinkenden Wertes Yen
berücksichtigen deutet alles auf eine
sich anbahnenden großen wirtschaftlichen
schrocken und wenn dazu noch die Importe
weiter viel schneller wachsen als die
Exporte könnte nahe Zukunft die
Kaufkraft der Japaner erheblich darunter
leiden
[Musik]
schon heute zeigt die aktuelle
reutersumfrage dass die Erwartungen
japanischer Unternehmen alles andere als
rosig sind und sie nun ernsthaft
befürchten dass die fallende Währung den
Konsum und die Investitionen übermäßig
Schwächen könnte das schweren kondenszu
dass die weltweite
Konjunkturabschwächung und insbesondere
die Auswirkung der Zero Corvette Politik
in China die japanischen Exporte noch
weiter Bremsen könnten denn ja China ist
der wichtigste Markt für japanische
Exporte schaut euch mal diese Grafik an
[Musik]
wenn diese Ereignisse eintreten könnte
die japanische Wirtschaft dann
erhebliches Loch in ihrem
außenhandelssektor ausbilden was
wiederum dazu beitragen würde den Wertes
hier noch weiter nach unten zu drücken
und damit letztendlich auch die
Kaufkraft der japanischen Bürger aber
aufgepasst denn das könnte nicht die
einzige Konsequenz bleiben die Abwertung
des Yen könnte auch andere
rivalisierende Volkswirtschaften in der
Region dazu veranlasst diesen Beispiel
so folgen so dass es am Ende zu einem
abwertungskrieg zwischen den großen
Exportnationen Asiens kommen könnte denn
wenn die Währung eines Landes abgewertet
wird schwächt das kurzfristig die
Wettbewerbsposition eines anderen Landes
in diesem Fall bedeutet es das ist nun
billiger wird Waren und Dienstleistungen
aus Japan zu beziehen als zum Beispiel
aus Südkorea weil der jene jetzt
billiger ist als der one und genau das
gleiche gilt selbstverständlich auch für
die anderen Länder und wisst ihr was
vielleicht hat diese Abwärtsspirale das
gegenseitige unterbieten sogar schon
begonnen schaut euch zum Beispiel mal
diese Grafik an
[Musik]
als Reaktion auf den Fall des Yen hat
China bereits damit begonnen seine
Währung gegenüber den Dollar abzuwerten
natürlich ist ein abwertungskrieg
letztendlich für niemanden eine
besonders lohnende und gutes Sache er
mag vielleicht den USA und Europa als
Abnehmerländern vorübergehend zu Gute
kommen aber letztlich könnten die
entstehenden Ungleichgewichte oft zu
hören Kosten führen als Japan zum
Beispiel 1997 den ihren abwertete um
sich vom Klassen seiner Immobilienblase
zu erholen übte es damit Druck auf
andere Länder in der Region aus dasselbe
zu tun das macht es damals schwierig auf
Dollar laufende Verpflichtungen zu
erfüllen und das Ergebnis war die große
Asienkrise von 1997
[Musik]
nun die alive visualpolitikfans Japan
ist ein Land mit vielen Tugenden und
seine Wirtschaft an den letzten Jahren
große Fortschritte gemacht zum Beispiel
hat sein fortschrittliche Industrie
wieder eine weltweite Führungsposition
eingenommen das Wirtschaftswachstum pro
Kopf übertrifft das vieler europäischer
Länder und das Land beginnt einige
Erfolge bei der Eindämmung der
Vergreisung seiner Bevölkerung zu
erzielen allerdings hat das Land der
aufgehenden Sonne auch ernsthafte
Probleme mit einem aktuellen
Wirtschaftsmodell seine Grenzen für
ausländische Direktinvestitionen zu
schließen und gleichzeitig zu versuchen
durch eine Abwertung seiner Währung
wettbewerbsfähiger zu werden ist in der
Regel keine langfristig effektive und
nachhaltige Strategie und während wir
noch auf neue Nachrichten aus Japan
warten laufen an den Finanzmärkten schon
die Wetten die lange die Bank of japane
ihren Kurs noch halten kann der weil die
anderen großen Notenbanken der Welt ihre
Leitzinsen nach und nach anheben doch
auch Japan hat die weltweite
wirtschaftliche Lage nicht kalt gelassen
die Rendite für japanische
Staatsanleihen mit zehn Jahren Laufzeit
wurde im letzten Monat dann doch über
die Schwelle von 0,25 auf 0,265%
angehoben aber nur um danach wieder auf
0,22% zu fallen dieses Video haben wir
nur einen Tag vor der Ermordung des
ehemaligen langjährigen Premierministers
shinsu Abi aufgenommen da an dieser
Stelle noch ein kurzes Update zu den
Auswirkungen des Attentats Japans
Regierungspartei und ihr
Koalitionspartner haben bei den
Parlamentswahlen am Sonntag einen großen
siegerrungen der möglicherweise durch
Sympathie Stimmen aufgrund des
Mordanschlags auf abbünstigt wurde mit
diesen nachhaltigen Boost seiner Partei
macht kann Premierminister von yukishida
ohne Unterbrechung bis zu den für 2025
geplanten Wahlen regieren und damit an
langfristigen politischen Zielen seiner
Partei Arbeiten hierzu wohl zählen die
Stärkung der nationalen Sicherheit in
erster Linie gegenüber China seine
charakteristische Wirtschaftspolitik des
neuen Kapitalismus und das lang gehegte
Ziel die von den USA entworfene
pazifistische nachkriegsverfassung zu
ändern eventuell bis hin zur
Stationierung von Atomwaffen die
Bedeutung all dieser Themen haben wir
euch bereits in unserem letzten Japan
video ausführlich erklärt nun dürfte
also auch der hier beschriebene Kurs
eine noch breitere politische
Unterstützung erfahren und kishida
könnte auch mit seiner Wirtschafts- und
Währungspolitik vor allem regelrechten
durchmar stehen es bleibt nur noch die
Frage wie schnell er damit auf die in
diesem Video aufgezeigten Probleme und
Nebenwirkungen stoßen wird wir dürfen
also gespannt bleiben wie sich der Plan
der Bank of Japan noch entwickeln wird
weswegen wie am Ball bleiben und euch
wieder über die neuesten spannenden
Entwicklungen im Land der aufgehenden
Sonne berichten werden aber jetzt seid
ihr erst mal an der Reihe glaubt ihr
dass die Regierungen und Zentralbanken
an ihren Plan festhalten sollten ihre
Währungen abzuwerten um
wettbewerbsfähiger zu werden was meint
ihr kann diese Strategie überhaupt
funktionieren oder wird es deswegen am
Ende wieder zu einer großen Asienkrise
wie vor 25 Jahren kommen welche
Auswirkungen wird Japans Wirtschaftsplan
auf den Weltmarkt haben wie immer sind
wir auf eure Beiträge und Diskussion zu
diesem Thema schon sehr gespannt ich
hoffe dass euch dieses Video gefallen
hat und ihr vielleicht auch etwas dabei
gelernt habt falls ja gibt es wieder ein
Like das mit euren Freunden und
vergessliches Abo mit Glöckchen um
keines unser Videos mehr zu verpassen
natürlich freuen wir uns auch jederzeit
über eine Spende von euch mit der uns
hält dieses Projekt weiterzuführen in
paypaling gasbuch findet ihr in der
Beschreibung unter den Video macht's gut
und bis bald
[Musik]